sí y además de texas y mississippi otros
dos estados se han sumado a esta lista
se trata de montana y iowa que están
recomendando dejar de usar la mascarilla
además pues ya había 11 estados en esta
unión americana que tampoco estaban
acogiéndose a las recomendaciones de
bioseguridad y al respecto pues ya
varios expertos de universidades de las
universidades más importantes de eeuu
están diciendo que es muy peligroso
teniendo en cuenta que texas tiene la
segunda población más grande de eeuu y
que tiene también la segunda población
contaminada más grande del país así que
dicen que la medida no solamente afecta
a estos estados y específicamente a
texas sino que afecta a todo el país
tampoco está claro ya que varios
almacenes de cadena están diciendo que
pues van a seguir obligando a usar el
uso de la máscara dentro de sus cadenas
de cadenas y tiendas como best buy o
incluso como target están diciendo que
la mascarilla la van a tener que seguir
usando así que
un poco está claro en qué lugares estos
ciudadanos van a poder dejar de usar la
máscara ya que incluso alcaldes locales
están pues contradiciendo esta medida de
parte de los gobernadores